none other than bob costas is on the
phone with us right now 28
emmy 7 you would never shortchange
yourself
you would no sooner shortchange yourself
an emmy than
al michaels would eat a green vegetable
bob
you know that's a good point but susie
you have just
given me insight into what my approach
should be going forward
for the rest of my career just select my
greatest hits
and let them play an extended version of
that rather than me having to come on
and try and think of something new to
say
we could all just pick like the 10 best
things we ever did
our lifetime batting averages would be
much higher
here's my question what haven't you said
yet let's think about that i mean with
the amount of olympics you've done
world series super bowl
what haven't you talked about yet
you know i have a few rants that my my
friends
uh like to have the reprise from now and
then which i will not do now but one has
to do
with how much i loathe parades
with the the only day of the year where
i have
any animus toward the group in question
is when they parade down fifth avenue
and make it impossible
for me to cross the street and everybody
else has to go around and around and
traffic has to be rerouted
and the police have to be have to be
employed or sent to police this parade
meanwhile meanwhile crime runs rampant
in gotham city and commissioner gordon
has to pick up the backbone
you know it's just all wrong and you
can't take your dog to the park to go to
the bathroom so what are you supposed to
do
it's ridiculous one hot 100 correct
360 days out of the year 365 in a leap
year
i am on your side in taxpayer expenses
costumes i'm out i love angry bob costas
i think we're all so used to your
america's voice in so many ways bob
and i feel like that when we get a
little bit of anger america in if that
is the case
by the way don't that's maybe not the
wrong conversation uh right conversation
to start with me
i think you know that uh that that said
um
but i do think it's fun to get angry bob
costas for a change i mean
we only get to see that in film
yeah now now and then of course this
friday on hbo and thank you for the lead
in this friday on hbo
is the premiere of back on the record
with bob costas
and if i am not exactly angry i will be
pointed at least at some points during
the hour which
follows bill more eleven o'clock eastern
time this coming friday night
i'm excited to have this back because i
was talking about this yesterday
there's been a loss of storytelling and
a loss of perspective and essays
because everyone's so busy yelling and
screaming at each other on a two screen
or a seven screen or what have you
i'm really excited to have this back on
the air bob not only at hbo but hbo max
what should we expect and what are you
looking forward to the most having this
back
in your saddle well i'm only doing
four a year it's supposed to be a
quarterly show
we got pushed back twice this year
because of covid so now we'll get four
in in 2021
by doing them in four consecutive months
july through october but going forward
it'll be quarterly
uh i'm interested in quality rather than
quantity at this point i don't want to
have a show hanging over my head
every week or every month and we're not
looking to duplicate or
do better by degree that which is
already out there
so it's not the same as real sports with
brian gumbel which is the 60 minutes of
sports
and is great on its own terms and it's
certainly not the same thing as the
debate shows
that we see on a daily basis all over uh
the dial the cable dial
some of that is fine some of the
opinions are insightful or humorous or
interesting
but a lot of people are doing it already
so
will this be exactly what every sports
fan
most enjoys no but everything now is a
niche and hbo
is for all of its prestige and there's
plenty of it and that's why i wanted to
be associated with them
again they do things at the highest
possible level
but it's still a boutique thing people
come to it
uh in lesser numbers than they come to
the nba finals or
the world series or whatever it might be
or certainly than the olympics even
during the pandemic
so we will find our audience what they
will
find us um and it will be it will remind
those
who are old enough to remember of some
of the things i used to do
it'll be a blend of commentary
of uh interviews that will not be
confined to three and a half minutes
there'll be some
depth to it and although the first show
has only sports figures
among uh those appearing in the past
especially on hbo
we had springsteen on the show we had
tina and seinfeld and
chris rock and jlo was on the show
clooney and hanks were on the show if
they like sports
and they have something to say about it
then we can branch out beyond sports
with them so that'll that'll be part of
it
i'm not trying to reinvent the wheel the
name of the show susie
tells you that it's back on the record
so
say same idea update a little bit and
hopefully i haven't lost my fastball
i expect greatness uh especially from
ross greenberg so there you go
i would love to know who to look forward
to watch on on this coming friday
edition
how the first show we have charles
barkley and he will be given uh
all the room he needs um ali raisman
which is
topical uh because of her outspokenness
about
the sexual abuse scandal in usa
gymnastics
and also because of what's happening
right now at the olympics and
especially today with the announcement
that simone biles has withdrawn at least
from
the team competition we'll see what
happens on the individual stuff and
we'll know about that because
the individual competition starts
thursday and we're on
on friday so ali is particularly uh
timely guest
and then you know like bill maher i will
have more in-depth interviews than bill
has but we'll have a panel
like he has so we'll have a panel of
people uh and we'll toss out whatever
seems topical or
appropriate to talk about given the
composition of the panel and then i'll
conclude it with
an essay or commentary of some kind and
then it'll be midnight and i'm not sure
what will be on hbo but i'll know by
friday
i'd love to hear your perspective bob
costas on simone biles today and about
her
openness uh about how she's feeling
mentally
on this world stage what are your
thoughts in that you've covered
pretty much every important olympian
that there is what were your thoughts in
watching her
and watching her perform this week
well she has every right to her own
feelings
and her own decisions on the
particulars of which i only understand
from a distance
it's very clear that her teammates love
and respect her
and that she will be there uh to cheer
them on even if she doesn't decide
to compete in the individual events
she's a very bright young woman she
understands
at some level what comes with the
territory and she's participated in it
willingly
and benefited from it she'll benefit
financially already has um
there's a goat meme which she has
associated with herself and she
certainly is the goat
of her particular sport
so she accepted being celebrated she
accepted being with all due respect to
katie ledecky and others
the face of this particular american
olympic team
she accepted all that probably knew at
some level
what came with it and at one point that
balance was worth it to her
but perhaps no one could have
anticipated uh including simone herself
all of the emotional pressure that comes
with
it if she is expected not just to excel
but to be perfect uh and
each individual is going to respond to
that in a different way
so i i don't i have no
uh reason to dispute or question her
reasons
or or her decision it i sympathize with
with everything that goes
that goes into it but there are both
benefits and drawbacks to being in small
small biles position she understands
that bob costas joins us here on the
rich eisen show back on the record with
bob costas premiering
friday july 30th at 11 p.m on hbo and on
hbo max
bob with the myriad interviews you've
done who has been the most
impactful to you
wow well you could say in a certain
sense although it certainly wasn't my
favorite um i think we handled it
confidently
the interview with jerry sandusky just
as the penn state
story was breaking nationally probably
had the greatest
measurable impact in that most of the
country concluded that night
that he was guilty he still disputes
that there are appeals
pending he has some defenders now in the
press
why they think he was railroaded or that
uh what he did was not
quite as god awful as what most people
now believe
i don't know how that will play out
we're ten years down the road
but certainly at the time that had a
tremendous impact
on the public understanding of the case
and what interview is out there that you
still
are searching for who's the person that
you haven't gotten yet
that you want to sit down across from
you
well you know this is maybe a
generational thing
all of us would love to see an interview
a truly
in-depth and candid interview with sandy
koufax
but i totally respect and even admire
sandy stance he's a private person by
nature
he's a humble person by nature and he
also has
what very few even the greatest of the
great
very few have this there's just no
disputing his place
in history and in the public imagination
he didn't have to win 300 games he was
done at 30 because of his arthritic
elbow
one less than 200 games but so
great and so elegant in such a short
period of time
what is there for him to defend or
explain he's probably better off not
just because of his
reticence and honest shyness but he's
probably better off
not even attempting to kill the lily or
go back down memory lane
every recollection of him from every
direction
is 100 percent well earned justified
admiration so so what can he do to
advance that
any further and every time i cross paths
with sandy
he is extremely gracious and it the last
time i asked him for an interview
was probably i don't know fifteen years
or so ago and he never used an
intermediary
he always called me back and the
conversation was something like this
susie
if i ever do it i'll do it with you and
then i began to realize
i'm at the front of a line that never
moves
having that designation as as the person
first in life
is pretty much meaningless yeah that's a
one-way ticket to know
yeah yeah although you know obviously
he's sort of like
you know in the literary world everyone
wanted the interview with jd salinger
right well with harper lee because they
were so reclusive
for a long time and he's kind of out of
the public eye now
think about this susie you always saw
jack nicholson
at laker games but jack nicholson
never did a television interview he
wouldn't even
go on with johnny carson when everyone
was blocking to johnny in the last month
wouldn't even go on with johnny carson
and his explanation
in the 90s was look i'm a movie star
you go to the movies they turn the
lights down it's a big screen
that's different than being on your
little home screen and people are
pottering around
i don't want to diminish that mystique
and you have to give that to him which
leads this story do you have a minute
for it
i always have a minute for you bob why
thank you susie so
1992 nba finals
the bulls in the trailblazers so it's
one of the games in chicago
and nicholson is in chicago um filming
hoffa
so he's a huge basketball fan not
surprising he can get good seats
not at center court like in la but
underneath one of the baskets along the
baseline
and somebody from nbc spots them and
the producer says bob do you know jack
nicholson
yeah i'm what kind of friendly
acquaintances he's down there
go ask him if he'll come on with you at
halftime now i'm way up in the rafters
in the old chicago stadium
i'm like guys this is a fool's errand
he's not gonna do it you owe it to us go
ask him okay like four minutes to go in
the second quarter
i go winding down the ramp and i wait
until a time out and i come up behind
him
and i tap him on his right shoulder and
his head
turns and i swear it reminded me of that
scene in the shining
i know that look i know it i know it
uh-huh yeah
so not there and then his face softens
and i wish i could do a good nicholson
impression he goes
oh hi bob and i say jack just play along
they're watching i'm supposed to ask you
if you'll come on at halftime and he
says verbatim
although i have to edit out one word
verbatim
bobby bobby you're a nice kid
you do good work how can i put this
no effing way
to which i say jack i take that as a
firm no enjoy the rest of the game
and now i gotta haul ass all the way
back upstairs i barely get uh get there
before the buzzer
to end the second quarter fool's errands
indeed
when i was a kid working at hbo sports
for real sports with brian gumbel and
ross
and the whole like i was doing a profile
on kobe bryant i was there with james
brown
i saw jack nicholson i said jb i'm going
to get an interview for
the kobe piece it'll be great he said
susie i will buy you whatever
classic convertible you want if you can
get that interview
i was like 20 something i had hubris
like jb watch this you know ask ross i
was a good booker back then
i tap him on the shoulder so i know that
look he swivels
i see the shining look mr nicholson i'm
susie schuster i'm a producer with hbo
sports
jb just told me he'll buy me whatever
classic car i want if i can get you to
do the interview he says kid
and i can't do the i can't do it either
stink you seem like a really nice kid
and you look really cute behind the
wheel of a car
but if i do it for you i got to do it
for everybody else
and i said oh come on please i don't
want to hear the word no
so yeah i get that look i've had that
look
it's not a good look but you know what
it leads to a good story decades later
and i tried did we and i tried bob
i can't wait to watch your show i'm very
excited
to watch it i will watch it religiously
the four times of the year
if you need any correspondence i'm just
saying you know i know people who work
you know you're the chief of the line
susie oh god that never moves
just said don't make it the same line
that's not good say hi to jill for me
please
i will thank you so much bob take care
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here